Well, I had to stop that
last presentation because
I ran out of time.
But now we can start up
right where we left off.
So far, we had figured out the
slope and it made sense to
us because we figured out
the slope was minus 4/3.
You could look at it two ways.
When the run is 3, the
rise is negative 4.
So rise we went down by
negative 4, we ran 3, and
you can keep doing that on
the line and you'll keep
ending up on the line.
You could've also gone down
8 and then moved over 6.
Or you could move over
6 and go down 8.
If you went down 8 you
would've showed up here.
Then you would've
come down back here.
Whatever the slope is, if you
change the y by the rise, and
you change the run by the
x, you should end up
on the line again.
I know I'm doing this over
and over again, but I think
it'll slowly sink in.
But anyway, where we left off
we were going to solve for b so
that we could figure out the
final equation for this line.
Well, just like we did the
last time, we just have to
substitute a y or an x that
we know works for this line.
We know either of these
coordinates will work,
and then we solve for b.
Let's try this first one:
2 comma negative 3.
So y is negative 3.
Don't get confused
between x and y.
y is negative 3 equals minus
4/3 times x, which is 2.
Plus b.
And then we get negative 3
equals negative 8/3 plus b.
And then we get b is equal to--
well, 3 is equal to minus 9/3.
And then I'm just going to
put this on the other side.
So that's plus 8/3.
So we get minus 1/3
is the y-intercept.
So the equation of this line is
y is equal to minus 4/3 x and
then this y-intercept
is minus 1/3.
I know this is extremely messy,
but the equation of this line
once again, is y equals
minus 4/3 x minus 1/3.
Now let's look at the graph
and see if that makes sense.
Well, let's see.
The y-intercept is right here.
That's where you intersect
the y-axis at the point.
And we would know exactly
what that point is.
It's 0 comma negative 1/3.
That's the y-intercept,
and it makes sense.
And even when you look at an
equation it's pretty obvious
that this is going to be the
y-intercept because when x
equals 0 this term
gets crossed out.
Because 0 times negative 4/3.
And then y would
equal negative 1/3.
Let's do one more
just to bore you.
And because my wife is a
resident and she works 30
hours of time and I have
nothing better to do.
All right.
Let me put that
graph back there.
I joke, but you don't
realize that it's true.
Let's put the graph back
there and I'm going to do
another random points.
I'm going to go a little
faster this time.
So let's say I had negative 8
comma 5 and I had-- let me
think of a good one-- 2
comma-- I'm just going
to make up a number.
2 comma, let's say 0.
That's interesting.
2 comma 0.
So let's graph
negative 8 comma 5.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Right there is minus 8 comma 5.
And then 1, 2, and
then 0 is right here.
So that's 2 comma 0.
And now let me draw the line.
Oh my God.
I thought I was using
the line tool.
That's horrendous.
I wish there was an undo tool.
That was horrendous.
That was unacceptable.
That's a little bit better.
Just so you know that the
line doesn't end there.
Lines go on forever and ever
in the coordinate axis.
There you go.
OK.
So let's figure out the
slope of this line.
Well, change in y
over change in x.
I'm using the line tool again.
I'm a spaz today.
Let's take this as
a starting point.
We'll get 5 minus 0.
y sub 1 minus y sub 2.
Over x sub 1-- minus 8 minus 2.
So it equals 5 over minus 10.
And that equals minus 1/2.
So that means for every 2
we go over, we go down 1.
Well, for every 1 we go
down, we go over 2,
which makes sense.
If we go down 2,
we'll go over 4.
Because 2/4 is the
same thing as 1/2.
I hope that makes sense to you.
I know this is a
downwards sloping line.
So that was fast.
So we know that the equation
of the line so far is y is
equal to minus 1/2 x plus b.
Now we just solve for b.
Let's substitute some
numbers in here.
Well, let's use this one.
This is interesting: 2 comma 0.
So y is 0.
Equals minus 1/2
times 2 plus b.
Well, 0 is equal to and
this is minus 1 plus b.
And we get b equals 1.
This is a pretty easy problem.
So now we get y is equal
to minus 1/2 x plus 1.
OK, now let's see if this
actually looks right
on our problem.
Well, this is telling us
that the y-intercept
is at the point 0, 1.
0, 1 is right here.
And our algebra
confirms our drawing.
This is the y-intercept
and we see that the
slope is negative 1/2.
It makes sense because it's
a downward sloping line,
but it's not too steep.
For every 1 that we go
down, we go over 2.
So that's negative 1/2.
Or you could say for every 2
we run, we rise negative 1.
Either one, we end
up on a line again.
So I hope that helps.
I think you are definitely
ready to do a lot of these
slope problems that we
have on the Khan Academy.
So I hope you have fun and if
you any questions you can
attend one of the seminars.
Have fun.